this catapult is launching what could be
the future of healthcare drones are
being used for everything from dropping
bombs to monitoring farms but this one
has a higher calling saving lives
the companies zip line is running test
flights in a quiet area of the
California coast but it has bigger plans
it wants to drop desperately needed
blood supplies to remote parts of Rwanda
Africa any nurse or doctor and place an
order via a text message will receive
that order we can take that product put
it into one of the aircraft we'll load
the aircraft for the battery the
aircraft goes onto the launcher and is
launched the vehicle will fly to the GPS
coordinates of that health center
ziplines partnering with UPS and with
Garvey which works to distribute
vaccines in the developing world and
their aim is to reach areas that are cut
off when the roads wash out other
companies are getting in on drone
delivery action Amazon wants to get our
impulse purchases to us faster Facebook
plans to connect the world to the web
and Google's project wing also wants to
deliver medicines or things like
batteries after disasters of course
there are advantages to testing in
developing countries it means things
like fewer regulations and a quieter
airspace but Rwanda will benefit if this
all works out - it will have the first
national drone delivery system that's
the kind of infrastructure that online
shoppers the world over can only Envy